l entrée fois ci trop quand je me suis
couché tard pour mettre au point un plan
de bataille c'est parti ben oui mais moi
la liste de tout ce qui pourrait
transformer cette super en vrai en
catastrophe c'est comme si c'était fait
est ce que quelqu'un sait écrire
météorite dégoût va falloir que rallye
sortent du lot mais tout en s'intégrant
pas qui a tué sur le coup riley sera
tellement gros que toutes les autres
filles en feront les cochons joie ou et
joie si toi tu resteras en commande je
veux que rallye soit de bonne humeur
et pendant que j'y suis je trouve ta
robe rubis sentence était gris c'est
sympa héros guindeuil tour
pas décharger les prix j'ai commandé des
réserves au cas où environ classe sage
précaution il ya des écoles on s'ennuie
même pendant la récré et je te paraîtra
le coeur non de tristesse
j'ai également une super mission
spéciale règles pour toi c'est vrai nous
avons
qu'est ce que tu fais voilà parfait ça
c'est le cercle de la tristesse toi tu
es là pour faire en sorte que toute la
tristesse
reste à l'intérieur